how's it goin everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
relating to Marvel and of course the MCU
we have had some major news just
recently be dropped yesterday and today
Mark Ruffalo talks about returning as
the Hulk not only returning for a TV
series she-hulk but also whether or not
he's going to return for his own movie
or team-up film and what that film could
be about not to mention that Taika
Waititi has recently teased that Hulk
could show up and Thor love and thunder
and also Mark Ruffalo mentioned again a
Hulk vs. Wolverine film and to top it
all off we have Hugh Jackman talking
about whether or not he is actually
considering coming back to Marvel to
play Wolverine
so we'll first start off by going over
the interview that Mark Ruffalo was
recently in where he talked about the
Hulk and then go into the Hugh Jackman
interview talking about Wolverine if
you're new be sure to subscribe and
notifications turned on to stay up to
date on everything happening in the MCU
and I'm also giving away an Xbox one or
ps4 at 550,000 subscribers almost there
so this first interview is with Mark
Ruffalo and a variety and it's the
interview where he drops another Hulk
vs. Wolverine bomb now of course
everybody wants Mark Ruffalo to return
to play the Hulk not everybody was
completely satisfied with his story arc
and Avengers in game and as it turns out
as revealed by Variety Mark Ruffalo
wants to return to play the character as
well now we've heard Mark Ruffalo kind
of talk about him returning to the MCU
and we've heard him say that he's had
meetings with Kevin Feige to talk about
the future of the Hulk and see if
there's anything there a lot of people
think that he is definitely returning
which would make a ton of sense but
here's what he had to say on the subject
when saying that he would like to return
he also added there's nothing completely
at a place where it's a done deal
there's some talk of having banner slash
the Hulk show up in the Disney Plus
Series she-hulk if we come up with
something good that would be really
interesting right now that's about it
that's all there is on the table however
he then went on to talk about a stand
alone Hulk film and what he would like
to see if that happened and he said
there's an idea that I think could be
really interesting
we never really followed him into his
life he's always kind of off on the side
he's like at the Rosencrantz and the
Guildenstern of the Avengers it'd be
interesting to fill in all the blanks
about what happened to him in between
all these movies which is kind of what
they did in Thor Ragnarok at the end of
Avengers age of Ultron the Hulk left
nobody knew what happened to him until
Thor Ragnarok the Mark Ruffalo wants an
entire solo Hulk film dedicated to what
he's done but of course before the
ending he again went on to say that he
would love to see a Holt vers Wolverine
film and he explained why the interview
explains that Mark Ruffalo grew up
reading comics but specifically Marvel
Comics x-men and Wolverine and he says
that now that Disney / Marvel has
purchased Fox and with it the rights to
the x-men characters and films and
Wolverine
maybe Hulk and Wolverine could hook up
now mind you this is the fourth time
that Mark Ruffalo has said a Hulk verse
one film is what he would like to see in
an official interview with a major media
outlet he 100% knows that people are
going to hear about this he 100% knows
that people like me are going to make
videos on it so it seems like something
is definitely going on here and not to
mention we've actually had previous
reports in the past several months ago
stating that there is a Hulk vs.
Wolverine film being talked about some
of you may recall that a Hulk vs.
Wolverine film was talked about last
year in September community scooper
Mikey Sutton mentioned on his Facebook
group that a Hulk vs. Wolverine film was
being talked about at marvel studios and
now many many months later
Mark Ruffalo in an interview has
expressed interest in a Wolverine vs.
the Hulk solo film for the fourth time
so clearly something is going on over at
Marvel Studios even if it's just mean
talked about for the current moment but
the real question is Hugh Jackman's
Wolverine and for having a Wolverine vs.
the Hulk film who is going to be the
Wolverine could the Hugh Jackman be
returning in mikey Sutton's original
report they said that they're going to
recast Wolverine it will not be Hugh
Jackman
he also said that it's probably several
years away well now we have an official
answer from a Hugh Jackman himself in an
interview the other day with The Daily
Beast Hugh Jackman opened up a lot he
talked a lot about his upcoming film bad
education and then of course he was
asked about Wolverine he talked about
how this year in June is going to be
twenty years since his debut as
Wolverine in the Fox x-men film and then
of course and the interview they had to
ask if he was returning and they said
you were great as Wolverine particularly
in Logan which was such a nice coda to
the character now that Disney and Fox
are merged it does seem like there are a
lot of possibilities for the x-men
universe to expand in ways that it
couldn't before and to that he replied
totally honestly Marlo if seven years
ago that had happened I'd be like oh
yeah but I knew it was the right time
for me to leave the party not just for
me but for the character somebody else
will pick it up and run with it
it's too good of a character not to it's
kind of like you're on your way home and
your friend rings you and goes oh dude a
new DJ just came on and the music is
awesome are you going to come back and
you say sounds good but no they're fine
with someone else so straight from the
mouth of Hugh Jackman himself he is done
with Wolverine and he even has mentioned
before that Logan was the perfect send
off and his goodbye to the character
Wolverine
now it is also important to note that
Patrick Stewart also said the same exact
thing but he has recently met with
Marvel Studios President Kevin Feige to
talk about Charles Xavier and the MCU
now it seems kind of clear that Patrick
Stewart is done but perhaps he could be
brought on board to consult for the new
Professor Xavier that is coming on
because clearly Kevin Feige talked to
him about plans Patrick Stewart said it
himself and if he's not returning what
she stated what else could he be doing
meeting with Kevin Feige he's giving
advice on the character he's helping
Kevin Feige with the direction and it
does seem like Professor Xavier is going
to be headed to the MCU before Wolverine
does but when that time comes
when Wolverine enters the MCU they will
most likely speak to Hugh Jackman about
the character
about the direction they want to go
about the stories they want to tell
because he was a great Wolverine we all
loved him and it's hard to imagine
anybody else's Wolverine right now and I
think that the saddest thing is about
this all is that he said if it was seven
years ago and this had happened Disney
had bought Fox he would have loved to do
it he would have loved to play Wolverine
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe seven
years ago not even like a full ten years
but only seven years ago and he would
have done it we missed him just barely
but hopefully he does come back and
consult with Marvel Studios about what
to do with the next Wolverine that's
going to enter the MCU but this does
leave us with the question of if we do
get a Hulk vs. Wolverine movie who is
going to play Wolverine which of course
we can't answer right now there's no way
of knowing and what direction are they
going to take the Hulk
well according to the same report that
Mikey stated way back in September we
are going to get some version of
immortal Hulk now for those of you who
are not aware of who immortal Hulk is
it's a very very different version of
the Hulk Professor Hulk that we saw in a
Vineyards in-game immortal Hulk could
quite possibly be the most terrorizing
Hulk that there is immortal Hulk is
brutal and he even punches holes through
planets but there's also a very big
psychological and emotional component to
immortal Hulk and if we think about
everything that's happened to Bruce
Banner and the Hulk since the very first
Avengers film all the way up to infinity
war and endgame there's definitely a
psychological side that we have not yet
explored with the Hulk but again if
Marvel Studios does go ahead and decide
to actually make a Wolverine versus Hulk
film it will probably be a few years
away which means that we will probably
see the Hulk show up before then and as
Mark Ruffalo mentioned in the interview
there are plans right now nothing
concrete but our plans for him to appear
and she hope and it makes perfect sense
because we just got the official
synopsis for she-hulk
and it reads following an injury
Jennifer Walters receives an emergency
blood transfusion from her cousin Bruce
Banner and acquires a milder version of
his Hulk condition as such Walters
becomes a large powerful green hewed
version of herself while still largely
retaining her personality in particular
she retains her
intelligence and emotional control
although like Hulk she still become
stronger if enraged and it's also been
revealed that shooting for the she-hulk
Disney Plus series is going to be
starting in July and will be filmed in
Atlanta the synopsis basically describes
exactly who Jennifer Walter is but the
big part is that just like in the comics
in this Disney Plus series Jennifer
Walters or she-hulk is going to become
the Hulk and get her condition from her
cousin who is Bruce Banner we all
assumed that they're going to show some
type of origin story for her how she
becomes the Hulk so it would just make
perfect sense that they would have Mark
Ruffalo as Bruce Banner in the show now
we probably won't get that much hulking
out from him he'll probably just step in
to save the day but he'll still be
Professor Hulk unless he somehow manages
to separate himself again which I don't
think is going to happen so it seems
like the first time that we're going to
see the Hulk return to the MCU is going
to be she-hulk but the great news is
that it does seem like Mark Ruffalo
really wants a Hulk vs. Wolverine film
and he's talked about it enough to make
us believe that he's definitely talked
to Kevin Feige about it and Marvel
Studios is definitely mulling it over
and even if we don't get Hugh Jackman
returning as Wolverine which it looks
like we're not going to it will still be
awesome to see a Hulk vs. Wolverine film
but let me know what you think about
this in the comments down below let me
know who you would like to play
Wolverine we're clearly not getting Hugh
Jackman back now so who's your second
pick let me know in the comments down
below and don't forget to like this
video and subscribe when notifications
turned on so you can stay up to date on
everything happening in the MCU for live
updates you can follow me on Twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof